cette émission consacrée à cette
troisième nuit de violence dans le pays
et au climat actuel qui règne dans ce
club aujourd'hui le constitutionnalisme
Benjamin Morel bonjour Benjamin merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous drissaf
bonjour merci d'être là vous êtes
docteur en droit public spécialiste des
questions de sécurité Samia nous a
rejoint rebonjour Samia on va parler
évidemment dans ce club de ces violences
urbaines qui ont émaillé le pays pour la
troisième nuit consécutive après la mort
du jeune Naël alors jusqu'où peut aller
cette embrasement est-il le signe d'une
fracture entre la jeunesse et la police
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez et
puis face à ces violences faut-il
instaurer l'état d'urgence c'est ce que
demande notamment à xiottier le patron
des républicains cette demande est-elle
justifiée que changerait-elle là aussi
évidemment on entendra votre avis mais
d'abord on va voir comment s'est passé
cette nuit dans nos régions
[Musique]
et on va aller du côté de Bourges on
retrouve Gladys Lafitte bonjour Gladys
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes rédactrice en chef adjointe au
Berry Républicain Gladys comment s'est
passé la nuit dans votre région
et bien ça a été très agité comme dans
beaucoup d'autres villes en France
effectivement la contagion est arrivée
jusqu'ici la nuit a été un petit peu
plus violente que la nuit précédente
malgré deux arrêtés préfectoraux l'un
pour interdire les engins pyrotechniques
et l'autre pour interdire le port des
armes et malgré ça vers une heure du
matin les violences ont commencé dans
les quartiers nord de Bourges il y a eu
une boulangerie qui a été complètement
saccagée la terrasse brûlée le mobilier
complètement détruit des barricades
beaucoup au milieu des routes des
poubelles brûlées quelques véhicules
brûlés aussi on a pu voir ce matin aussi
dans les rues des cendres des arrêts de
bus avec des vitres qui étaient
complètement brisées une mairie annexe
qui a été aussi visée en tout on
dénombre à ce stade dans les éléments
sont en train d'être consolidés et de
remonter mais une quarantaine
d'interventions de pompiers comme le
disait tout à l'heure mettre Henri
Leclerc c'était vraiment un mouvement
spontané dans dans cette ville de
Bourges il faudra voir à Vierzon où il y
a eu aussi quelques événements la nuit
précédente mais clairement on était sur
un niveau au -dessus cette nuit là on a
aussi assisté à ce phénomène où voilà
les personnes se parlaient sur les
réseaux sociaux on avait l'impression
qu'il se lançait presque des défis voilà
pour pour agir dans ces quartiers Nord
ici à Bourges
la région n'est pas connue pour avoir
des quartiers qui s'enflamment à la
moindre étincelle
non en tout cas plus connu c'est vrai
que ici à Bourges il y a des quartiers
qui sont les quartiers Nord où il y a
effectivement du trafic de stupéfiants
où il peut y avoir des événements un
petit peu de manière sporadique mais en
tout cas depuis 2005 en tous c'est ce
que nous disent nos interlocuteurs
depuis 2005 vraiment on n'avait pas vu
ça jamais jamais les feux de poubelle
c'est vraiment très rare les feux de
voiture ça arrive de temps en temps mais
c'est pour des événements très précis
donc effectivement on n'est pas dans un
dans une dans une zone de la France qui
est qui est connu pour connaître ce type
d'événements d'autant plus qu'il y a eu
un vrai travail de la politique publique
ici à Bourges il y a eu de la rénovation
urbaine il y a eu des politiques
publiques qui ont été mises en place de
l'argent qui a été investi des
animations qui existent aussi ici que ce
soit au niveau des institutions de la
mairie mais aussi des habitants qui font
vivre leur quartier par exemple je peux
vous donner cet exemple cet événement
qui commence aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
la Coupe du Monde des quartiers où il y
a une vingtaine d'équipes qui
s'affrontent dans qui s'affrontent de de
manière très très populaire et très
joyeuse ici dans les quartiers nord ça
devrait commencer ce soir ça dure ça
dure une semaine et voilà ça c'est des
animateurs des gens qui vivent ici et
qui font vivre leur quartier et qui font
vivre cette ferveur et se vivre ensemble
et ce sont des événements très familiaux
et ce sera d'ailleurs un papier à lire
dans l'édition de demain et on les réa
évidemment tout ça on regarde la une de
l'édition d'aujourd'hui Gladys
l'embrasement c'est le titre choisi par
le Berry Républicain une grande partie
des journaux du groupe centre france
merci beaucoup merci Gladys d'avoir été
avec nous Drissa Youcef on entendait un
Gladys nous dire que dans sa région
c'était des événements qu'elle n'avait
pas vu depuis 2005 on est dans un
embrasement dans quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce qui s'est passé dans les
banlieues il y a quelques années je
pense qu'en tout cas l'intensité est
plus forte alors qu'on est à peine au
troisième jour en tout cas troisième
nuit d'émeutes
à titre de comparaison c'est vrai qu'en
2005 c'était un mouvement un petit peu
plus politique on se souvient des jeunes
qui prend tissaient leurs cartes
d'identité et qui revendiquait une
appartenance et une nation et que cette
mort atroce de ces deux jeunes adebou
nats dans un transformateur électrique
avec complètement bouleversé un peu
l'opinion publique là c'est un peu
différent on n'a pas à faire un espèce
de mouvement politique c'est à la suite
effectivement de ce drame humain ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'en 2005 on a été
plutôt sur quelque chose de défensif on
défendait son territoire on refusait
l'accès aux policiers et on joue au chat
et à la souris dans les coursifs de la
cité on est sur quelque chose de
différent on prend d'assaut une prison
on attaque des commissariats on va au
centre-ville on dégrade des biens
publics des transports en commun ce qui
était pas tellement le cas en 2005 donc
l'intensité est plus forte alors même
que c'est la troisième nuit des
Benjamin un mot et puis après on va
écouter ce que disait mettre Henri
Leclerc justement sur cette comparaison
avec 2005 oui en effet j'ajoute café ce
qui a été dit je dirais que ce qui est
très très marquant c'est l'absence
devrait revendication l'absence je
dirais de structure au mouvement et
au-delà de ça de fondement qui serait
perceptible et pour les pouvoirs publics
c'est évidemment peut-être encore plus
compliqué à gérer parce qu'à l'époque
souvenez-vous du discours de Jacques
Chirac et bien tout le monde est citoyen
etc il y a une volonté d'inclusion dans
le discours politique qui permet de
trouver une solution politique à un
mouvement qui est un mouvement de
contestation à but malgré tout politique
là on est face à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus protéiforme et qui en soit
en ça est très à l'image aujourd'hui et
bien d'une forme de contestation
sous-jacente sans revendication sans
vrai force mais symptomatique d'un vrai
vrai malaise
ce que disait il y a quelques minutes
sur ce plateau mettre Henri Leclerc sur
cette tension qui règne dans les
quartiers et cette comparaison avec les
élèves de 2005
et je connais malheureusement nous
savons bien d'ici l'extrême tension
qu'il y a actuellement dans un certain
nombre de quartiers et
le quartier il y a des gens les jeunes
tout le problème des banlieues comme on
dit entre guillemets et nous savions et
nous savions qui n'éluquablement il y
avait y avoir une révolte ceux qui ont
vu récemment le film Les Misérables là
qui montrent justement ça dans une
banlieue grande partie mais bon on avait
tous le souvenir bien entendu de des
événements de 2005 de ces gosses qui
avaient été brûlés et et ça moi j'ai dit
ça va ça va arriver et malheureusement
c'est arrivé c'était inéluctable qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui dans
le pays pour vous
pour dire les choses franchement
à plusieurs reprises sur plusieurs
plateaux à titre personnel j'ai indiqué
que le ministre de l'intérieur quand il
est nommé il a toujours une réaction en
tout cas une espèce de travers qui
consiste à dire moi je réglerai le
problème de la sécurité en France et
j'ai toujours compte considéré y compris
entre PC sur les questions de sécurité
que c'était une base de fumisterie on a
un problème aujourd'hui avec nos
jeunesses il y a pas une jeunesse dans
le pays il y a des jeunesses et on a une
dégradation de la d'une des jeunesse
depuis maintenant plusieurs années quand
on regarde le système éducatif
aujourd'hui c'est un système éducatif
une des jeunesse vous avez par exemple
la jeunesse qui est dans l'oisiveté une
partie de la jeunesse qui est dans la
délinquance une partie de la jeunesse
qui travaille donc il y a d'autres
aspirations telles que la santé sortir
de la précarité une partie de la
jeunesse qui est en apprentissage et qui
est entre l'éducation etc donc vous avez
des jeunesses et force cette constater
qu'on a une de ces jeunesses voire même
deux parties tunnels qui sont dans une
difficulté soit dans une précarité et
qui n'ont pas suffisamment en tout cas
ça a été en tout cas quitter le cursus
scolaire le cours scolaire trop tôt et
donc
la situation de notre système éducatif
est complètement au bout de souffle vous
regardez l'enseignement supérieur il y a
des dizaines de milliers de gamins qui
n'ont pas accès à l'enseignement
supérieur dans le pays qui sont ces
gamins généralement les plus précaires
généralement le plus qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ensuite qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah
des scolarisation c'est quoi c'est
l'antichantes de la délinquance de la
radicalisation donc deux focaliser de
donner beaucoup de moyens la police
région gendarmerie il y a pas de
difficulté mais le système éducatif il
est il est à bout de souffle en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous avez trois mois
avant qu'un professeur de mathématiques
soit remplacé c'est une réalité la
politique de la ville elle a fait du
bien en ce qui disent que c'est pas elle
a fait du bien ça a permis d'embellir
des territoires ça permet de relier tes
transports avec les transports sur des
bassins d'emploi ça permet de créer de
l'emploi il y a eu des choses qui ont
été faites c'est vrai il faut l'admettre
en revanche sur l'éducation c'est un des
a donc tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
donc pour vous c'est une trajectoire on
n'est pas juste dans une rupture entre
la police et la jeunesse des quartiers
on n'est pas juste dans une in en tout
cas vécu comme tel par cette jeunesse
des quartiers on est dans autre chose on
est dans le l'expression d'une jeunesse
désemparée on est totalement dans
l'expression d'une jeunesse désemparée
a-t-elle enseigne qu'on voit bien qu'il
y a pas de revendications politiques il
y a pas un mouvement une organisation
une fédération d'association qui porte
ce mouvement de contestation qui aurait
pu être populaire parce que en définitif
il faut que la mobilisation il faut que
la colère elle puisse s'exprimer mais de
manière pacifique et derrière avec des
revendications si on veut travailler un
dispositif politique or c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui on a affaire à des moules à
des mouvements et une volonté de s'en
prendre bien public et aux forces de
sécurité c'est pas un message politique
en tout cas c'est pas le bon
oui un sentiment de relégation et
d'abandon il faut voir que ces quartiers
ils ont été conçus quasiment comme des
quartiers hub lorsque vous avez une
ascension sociale qui se produit et bien
les gens ont parc et donc vous avez une
population qui est dans ces quartiers
qui souvent est une population en
difficulté et qui ne boit pas debout en
réalité à ces difficultés alors on
insuffle des services publics mais ces
services publics deviennent assez
rapidement dysfonctionnel et un tissu
économique qu'en effet on essaye
d'établir Emmanuel Macron les zones
franches etc a essayé également de faire
quelque chose mais fondamentalement on a
une fragilité dans ces territoires qui
est inhérent aux populations même qui ne
voit pas d'avenir
pour eux-mêmes et pour ces territoires
donc lorsque vous êtes dans
les politiques ne leur n'ont pas donné
parce que les politiques n'auront pas
donné parce que entre guillemets on a on
a concentré la misère c'est à dire qu'on
a considéré que on avait la des
territoires qui étaient des territoires
justement et bien qui étaient des
territoires hub qui étaient des
territoires qui devaient justement être
aidé être soutenu mais qui en aucun cas
et bien ne représenterait demain ne
représenterai jamais demain des poumons
la Californie en Seine-Saint-Denis
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est encore et ce
sera probablement toujours un rêve à ce
rythme là donc tant qu'on a pas une
vision qui est une vision réelle de
développement de ces territoires et m'a
malheureusement vous aurez des
populations qui se sentiront en
relégation et je rejoins tout à fait ce
qui a été dit aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
parlé en tout début d'année la
difficulté qu'on pouvait avoir
aujourd'hui de recruter un enseignant et
le fait le speed dating pour avoir des
contractuels souvenez-vous à la réalité
c'est que le rectorat de Versailles la
plupart du temps vous prenez des
contractuels à Tours de pelle la plupart
du temps ils sont pas très compétents
parce qu'ils sont formés en trois jours
vous les envoyez face à des classes qui
sont évidemment des classes difficiles
parce que jeunes des quartiers
populaires c'est pas facile il faudrait
des enseignants chevronnés sauf qu'on en
trouve pas et donc ce faisant vous avez
des gamins qui n'ont pas le capital
culturel initial à la maison etc pas les
parents qui ont les moyens de payer les
profs particuliers qui se retrouvent
face à des enseignants mal formés dans
le cadre d'école qui sont des écoles
dysfonctionnelles et qui ensuite ne s'en
sortent pas et on se demande pourquoi
moi je me souviens il y a deux ans
sortir du covid avoir alerté une autre
personnalité de l'État en disant écouté
moi j'ai une vraie problématique une
inquiétude parce que post covid il y a
des milliers de gamins qui manquent à
l'appel ils ne sont pas retournés à
l'école et donc il fallait
impérativement mettre en place une
espèce de mission interministérielle
pour essayer d'aller les comptabiliser
et aller les chercher ma républu que
c'était pas forcément la priorité qu'on
avait d'autres priorités ces gamins qui
sont sortis à 13 ou 14 ans du système
scolaire c'est ce qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui en train de se déchirer sur
la voie publique prenez le petit nail
épée à son âme à 17 ans sera intéressant
aussi un moment donné de regarder
d'analyser la trajectoire quand est-ce
qu'il a quitté l'école et pour quelles
conditions est-ce que le covid c'est il
y a trois ans et cette situation vous la
voyez un peu partout en France vous
prenez les rapports de police d'analyse
on vous dit que la moyenne d'âge des
gamins qui s'entretuent qui meurent sur
la voie publique à cause des règlements
de compte trafic de drogue n'est passé
du Moyen-Âge de 27 ans à 23 ans même pas
un an et demi
c'est très compliqué donc on a vraiment
à faire aujourd'hui à une jeunesse qui
est une jeunesse qui est désemparée
alors c'est vrai sujet il y a la
parentalité sujet beaucoup de sujets à
traiter dedans tout ça mais au fond si
on refuse de prendre des problèmes
sérieusement à bras le corps et ben on
va voir une génération qui va arriver
qui va être extrêmement difficile avec
laquelle on va avoir du mal à travailler
et une génération qui est perdue ce sont
des décennies qui sont perdus et du coup
cette colère elle est là elle s'exprime
en tout cas ces trois dernières nuits
comment on répond comment on sort de ces
émeutes qu'elle doit être la réponse
pour vous dire c'est Youssef moi je
pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui il y a le le
l'apaisement qui est indispensable
vraiment l'apaisement c'est les élus
locaux les associations les parents y
compris ce la même qui aujourd'hui
participe à ces dégradations c'est
l'apaisement le moment du recueil du
deuil et ensuite comment on construit
des choses assez froidement et comment
on met tout le monde autour de la table
c'est aussi de la fermeté en réponse
il faut de la fermeté mais souvenez-vous
pardon mais le les mots prononcé par le
président de la République sur la
décibilisation au fait tout le monde
s'est jeté sur le mot personne n'a fait
du fond tous se dit mais attendez je
suis content je suis d'accord je suis
pas d'accord mais personne n'a fait du
fond et personne n'a dit bon d'accord ok
on est tous d'accord sur le constat
notre société elle va mal qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de quoi on parle et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait demain personne n'est allé
là-dedans ils se sont tous échappés sur
un mot voilà aujourd'hui la réalité de
notre pays c'est-à-dire qu'on fait pas
de politique et on s'accorde sur des
mots on se déchire sur des mots est-ce
qu'on peut apporter une réponse
politique comment on fait pour apporter
une réponse politique à un mouvement
vous le disiez tout à l'heure qui n'est
pas politique et qui ne pose pas de
revendications
aujourd'hui tout le monde sait ce qui se
passe dans un certain nombre de
territoire on sait ce qui se passe on a
des diagnostics comme on en dégage des
politiques publiques c'est ceux qui sont
responsabilités qui doivent regarder les
choses froidement moi je suis pas
d'accord pour critiquer le président de
la République sur le Conseil présentiel
des villes parce qu'il y a des choses
qui ont été faites et c'est pas parce
qu'on a un ministre de plein exercice de
la politique de la ville que sera mieux
demain d'ailleurs la preuve on en a eu
auparavant et ça a pas forcément marché
donc là aujourd'hui c'est regarder
froidement le sujet de lier de la
jeunesse on a travaillé sur à peu près
tous les secteurs globalement
économiquement ça va bien la question
d'emploi la question des transports il y
a des moyens qui sont mis la jeunesse il
faut regarder les choses jusqu'à présent
on sait pas bien occupé de la jeunesse
ou des jeunesse dans notre pays et donc
je pense que politiquement il faut
pouvoir y répondre et force cette
constater que les échecs de Jean-Michel
Blanquer c'est une réalité les parents
le constatent et en particulier ceux
issu des quartiers populaires
pardonnez-moi et encore une dernière
chose initiative prise par le Président
de la République qui est dire on va
garder les enfants de 8 heures à 18h
c'est une excellente chose pourquoi
parce que dans ces territoires vous avez
beaucoup de familles monoparentales
absolument voilà vous avez beaucoup de
familles monoparentales des femmes qui
élèvent seul leur gamin et qui sont
obligés d'aller travailler cumuler deux
trois emplois pour financer qu'est-ce
que le gamin fait quand il est encore à
l'école à 16h30 ensuite bah il est sur
la voie publique et ensuite c'est le
début du décrochage scolaire donc de les
garder jusqu'à 18 h à la condition d'y
mettre du contenu et de la culture on
peut arriver à des résultats
intéressants mais il faut y mettre des
moyens et c'est je pense dans
l'éducation qu'il faut sur l'éducation
sur laquelle il faut travailler
revenir sur sur ses émeutes et sur ce
qui s'est passé et l'une des réponses
qui est demandée par la droite en tout
cas Samia c'est l'instauration de l'état
d'urgence alors qu'est-ce que cet état
d'urgence changerait en quoi c'est en
quoi il consiste exactement alors c'est
un régime d'exception qui a été créé
dans un contexte très particulier en
1955 en plein en pleine guerre d'Algérie
après une série d'attentats du FLN cette
année-là on vote donc une loi pour créer
l'état d'urgence qui sert à rétablir la
sécurité publique en cas de péril
imminent dû à des attentes graves à
l'ordre public ou en cas de calamité
publique comme une catastrophe naturelle
alors concrètement qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire bien ça veut dire que le ministre
de l'Intérieur il est préfet peuvent
interdire les manifestations fermer des
lieux publics ou des lieux de culte
instauré un couvre-feu décidé
d'assignation à résidence ou encore
lancer des perquisitions administratives
donc vous l'avez compris c'est une
restriction temporaire des libertés pour
assurer par ailleurs la sécurité
nationale
pas confondre avec l'état d'urgence
sanitaire créé en 2020 au monde
l'épidémie de covid 19 et on s'en
souvient tous la plus loin puisqu'il a
vu conduit au confinement du pays à ne
pas confondre non plus avec l'état de
siège en cas de guerre qui confie les
pouvoirs de police et certains pouvoirs
de justice à l'armée alors qui peut
déclencher cet état d'urgence c'est le
président de la République Oriane qui
peut le faire par décret en Conseil des
ministres l'état d'urgence est alors
instauré pour 12 jours et il ne peut
être prolongé que par un vote du
Parlement alors ça n'arrive quand même
pas si souvent puisque c'est je le
rappelle un régime d'exception qui est
donc réservé des situations
exceptionnelles depuis sa création
l'état d'urgence a déjà été décrété 6
fois trois fois pendant la guerre
d'Algérie donc au moment où il a été
créé une fois en 1985 en
Nouvelle-Calédonie suite aux
affrontements entre partisans et
opposants de l'indépendance en 2005 on
en parlait tout à l'heure un état
d'urgence a été décrété dans 25
départements pour mettre fin à ce qu'on
a appelé à l'époque les émeutes des
banlieues notamment à l'aide de
couvre-feu et puis plus récemment suite
aux attentats 2015 l'état d'urgence est
déclenché sur une période
particulièrement longue puisqu'il va
tout de même durer deux ans jusqu'en
2017 Benjamin est-ce que cette demande
de la droite direction est justifiée ce
déclenchement de l'état d'urgence
objectivement je pense pas c'est à dire
que alors 2015 en effet on en est sorti
en 2017 on en est sorti à travers la loi
silt qui reprenait une partie de la loi
de 55 pour la faire entrer dans le droit
commun on a une forme d'accoutumance
aujourd'hui aux États d'exception parce
que en effet état d'urgence sanitaire
qui reprend quand même certaines
dispositions la loi de 55 en 2020 là
aussi on a des choses qui sont rentrées
dans le droit commun bref on s'habitue à
vivre en état d'exception permanente et
l'état d'exception devient même quelque
chose de facile parce qu'en réalité on a
l'impression que si on rentre en état
d'exception on va régler le problème là
soyons pragmatique qu'est-ce que ça
règle alors le seul apport qui serait
potentiellement intéressant c'est celui
du couvre-feu couvre-feu qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas forcément basé uniquement sur
l'état d'urgence de couvre-feu en droit
français ça existe pas vraiment en
réalité donc on avoir découvre ce locaux
etc sur certaines populations ça existe
sans même état d'urgence et donc on peut
malgré tout faire des choses à quoi
servirait un couvre-feu actuellement bon
c'est vraiment que les gamins qui
manifestent et qui brûle des banques et
on se dire ah il y a un arrêté municipal
donc je pense sincèrement que en faisant
ça on met plus de lui sur le feu parce
que comment est-ce que ça va être
entendu c'est ça qui est important
rebelote 2005 donc une certaine façon
vous légitimez le mouvement et de
l'autre côté et ben terroriste en 2015
et nous la même chose donc
stigmatisation donc je crains que le
signal politique soit mauvais même ça
peut être bon pour une partie de
l'électorale d'un point de vue purement
électoraliste mais si on veut calmer le
jeu le signal est mauvais et
juridiquement objectivement ça sert pas
à grand chose
il y a quelque chose qui me frappe des
postures politiques c'est que on passe
enfin pas ça leur temps à dire et à
raison pour le coup qu'il faut laisser
faire le travail justice c'est important
etc et on propose la réactivation de la
loi de 55 la loi de 55 quelle est la
différence entre un régime de droit
commun ces dispositions se sont confiées
à l'autorité administrative des pouvoirs
exceptionnels c'est le préfet qui va
pouvoir décider du couvre-feu des
perquisitions un peu administratives etc
alors que la liberté en tout cas la
restriction liberté parce qu'on est tous
attaché à l'autre constitution c'est
l'article 66 qui confère à l'autorité
judiciaire le gardienne de la liberté
individuelles et donc il faut pouvoir un
moment donné faire confiance à la
justice moi je suis totalement opposé
comme j'ai toujours été sur la loi de 55
ou sur l'état d'urgence parce que je
crois que je suis complètement d'accord
avec Benjamin cette espèce de facilité
comme disait d'ailleurs Henri Leclerc
c'est progressivement transféré des
pouvoirs d'exception dans le régime
droit commun parce que c'est très facile
de se passer du jugement des c'est dire
mon temps de préfet je vais prendre des
initiés et je rappelle qu'il y a de la
jurisprudence notamment sur des actes
administratifs qui ont été pris contre
des individus sur lesquels il existait
d'ailleurs même pas de soupçons
simplement une note blanche ont été
retoquées par le Conseil d'État donc je
suis totalement posé à ça d'autant plus
que je trouve que ça n'aura absolument
aucun un impact sur la mobilisation
actuelle il y a une loi aussi qui fait
des basses et la loi de février 2007 qui
est régie les 2017 pardon qui régit les
les tirs des policiers vous avez
travaillé vous sur cette loi Drissa
Youssef est-ce que vous comprenez que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon disent que c'est un
permis de tuer non ce n'est pas la
vérité la loi de février 2017 sur la
sécurité publique elle permettait
d'avoir été dans un contexte post
attentat et de donner la possibilité aux
forces de l'ordre qui est pas un permis
de tuer la possibilité ou en tout cas
d'encadrer l'utilisation de l'arme à feu
des forces de l'ordre en particulier les
policiers parce qu'avant les policiers
dépendaient comme vous et de moi du
régime de droit commun c'est-à-dire
celui de la légitime défense et donc il
y a cinq conditions il y a cinq
conditions politisations et puis ça
permettait aussi d'aligner sur le régime
des gendarmes
et quand on regarde par exemple sur les
refus d'obtempérer avec un véhicule et
bien précisé dans la dernière
disposition article 435-1 code de la
sécurité intérieure que c'est
effectivement sur une menace imminente
sur une menace physique etc etc et donc
celui qui apprécie vous avez à la fois
des jurisprudence mais c'est le juge je
suis judiciaire donc la réalité c'est
que vous avez eu effectivement un pic de
de
usage d'armes à feu sur des refuses
d'obtempérer en 2017 et puis ensuite ça
progresse difficilement diminué pourquoi
parce qu'il y a eu effectivement une
adaptation c'est toujours comme ça le
politique vote des lois et
l'administratif derrière ne suit pas ou
je ne suis pas tout le temps et donc il
y a eu des adaptations il y a eu des
explications de la formation
accompagnement des policiers pour dire
attendez l'usage arme à feu c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe etc donc ça
diminué mais la réalité c'est que c'est
pas un permis tué loin de là mais le
niveau de d'utilisation des armes à feu
suite à 2017 effectivement ABC mais il
reste plus élevé qu'avant qu'avant cette
loi d'une vingtaine de tirs en moyenne
en plus par an oui mais parce que vous
avez complètement raison et parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'il y a plus de
contrôle faut pas oublier qu'il y a de
plus en plus de tension entre une partie
de la population et les forces de
l'ordre et c'est qui explique encore une
fois je cherche pas à justifier l'usage
de l'arme à feu au milieu je dis
expliquer un contexte et encore une fois
vous avez aussi certains politiques qui
vous savez la présomption de légitime
défense et c'était consiste à dire que
en fait c'est ni plus ni moins que le
renversement de la charge de la preuve
c'est pas la victime ou la famille c'est
pas aux policiers de prouver qu'il a mal
agi mais c'est à la victime famille de
victimes de prouver que c'est eux qui
ont bien agi et donc le problème c'est
que le juge judiciaire tout ça et s'en
fout comme pour ce policier il a
expliqué un centre de choses le poly le
magistrat à regarder le dossier il a
considéré qu'il y avait une mise en
examen et donc c'est un moment donné
c'est aussi le politique qui fait
espérer les forces de sécurité et en
particulier les policiers en leur
donnant une espèce de protection
juridique qui en réalité n'existent pas
compte tenu des faits donc oui la loi de
2017 elle a permis de répondre à un
contexte grave de notre pays et pour
autant ça n'a jamais été impermé tué ça
n'a jamais été enseigné comme ça mais si
cette affaire pour l'instant nous dit
quelque chose c'est que le cadre légal
n'est justement pas si mauvais ce que le
policier en question si vous entendez le
procureur de la République il y a
clairement une incrimination et donc ce
faisant dire que on serait dans une
situation de violence policière
systémique etc impliquerait que il y a
pas de justice derrière qui est pas
d'enquête derrière qui est pas de
sanction derrière or ce que montre ici
cette affaire c'est que et bien il y a
une justice que justement la République
prend en compte ce type de situation et
que la loi en question quand vous faites
un usage immodéré disproportionné
criminel de votre arme et bien vous
pouvez être sanctionné sans préjugés
évidemment de la décision de justice
infinie mais en tout cas la question est
réellement posée donc on peut réfléchir
ensuite au cadre légal à une réforme de
l'IGPN etc tout ça oui mais dire la
police tu dire de l'autre côté et bien
on a une des violences policières qui
sont des violences policières
systémiques ce que prouve cette affaire
c'est que non justement est-ce que
disent certaines personnes à gauche
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de
récupération politique est-ce qu'il y a
des personnalités à gauche qui souffrent
un peu sur les braises réessaye que
cette fois ça va être tout le sujet de
postes je peux m'exprimer ainsi j'espère
que rapidement on va arriver à la
normale mais on a d'ores et déjà des
organes rapidement pour vous en tout cas
je l'espère on va voir encore quelques
moments difficiles mais je pense que
faudrait qu'on arrive à la normale assez
rapidement pour essayer de poser un
débat mais d'ores et déjà on voit bien
il y a des positionnements politiques
qui sont par ailleurs pas acceptables
quand on dit que la police est racisée
en tout cas qu'elle ne tue que les noirs
et les Arabes dans le dans les quartiers
c'est profondément scandaleux et c'est
faux je connais beaucoup de policiers
issus de la diversité je ne connais pas
un policier fils de millionnaire au fils
de milliardaire ce sont des gens qui
rentrent par vocation pour protéger les
Français quel que soit leurs origines
culturelles culturelles sociales et donc
voilà qui est effectivement des
dysfonctionnements ça a toujours été un
peu mon combat sur la formation sur
l'encadrement c'est un vrai sujet il y a
des déficiences c'est une réalité on
balance des gamins de 21 ans avec des
fusils mitrailleurs sur la voie publique
alors qu'ils sont pas totalement formés
combien de fois on n'a pas dit sur le
lanceur de bac de défense il y a des
déficiences en matière de formation
c'est une réalité mais de dire que la
police est raciste dans notre pays c'est
une honte de dire qu'effectivement ce
sont sans prennent uniquement au noir
aux Arabes c'est une onde mais on voit
bien que dans tout ça il y a une
récupération politique qui se prépare
parce que on voit bien que d'un côté le
rassemblement national qui soutient
aveuglement une police ou en tout cas
des policiers qu'il faut savoir
quelquefois condamner et puis on voit
bien qu'il y a d'autres organisations
qui jouent après et après va être un peu
compliqué parce que ce qui va être
important c'est de faire France ensemble
c'est de se réunir sur effectivement un
constat sur un diagnostic toutes les
organisations politiques la réalité
extrême droite comme extrême gauche joue
d'après plutôt que de jouer l'apaisement
essaie de construire quelque chose on
voit bien que on prépare après
tout le monde fait de la politique et
c'est très dommage et très dangereux au
vu de la circon au vu des circonstances
un peu cocotte-minute après si vous
regardez les enquêtes d'opinion je serai
tenter de vous dire que cyniquement
c'est pas si étonnant c'est un sujet
extrêmement idéologisé et extrêmement
clivant electorat de gauche pense que il
y a des violences policières systémiques
en majorité et que en effet il y a du
racisme dans la police le lectorat de
droite arrive en soutien massif à la
police on considère souvent que les la
porosité gauche droite et que les
frontières sont fous sur ce sujet là
elles sont idéologiquement structurantes
mais à la base de présupposés on l'a dit
la situation est fondamentalement
complexe là l'idéologie passe devant la
complexité pour le politique c'est dur à
gérer et ça crée des réactions
parunistes et ces émet urbaines font
évidemment la une de la presse régionale
ce matin on voit ça tout de suite avec
Samia
[Musique]
et Samia les violences de la niche pour
la Une de toute la presse régionale ce
matin oui l'embrasement c'est le terme
qui revient à la Une de plusieurs titres
le Berry Républicain qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure mais aussi le bien public ou
encore La Dépêche du Midi on choisit les
mêmes mots pour revenir sur la journée
et d'hier à Nanterre qui s'est terminé
dans la violence mais aussi dans de
nombreuses villes de France cette murène
le nord par exemple a été fortement
touché cette nuit encore oui colère KO
et désolation peut-on lire ce matin dans
la Voix du Nord avec un reportage dans
des quartiers entre colère et sidération
Roubaix Tourcoing encore mons-en-barœul
où je rappelle que la mairie a
entièrement brûlée je ne pensais pas que
ça pouvait arriver ici raconte un
habitant dans les colonnes du journal la
Normandie n'a pas été épargnée non plus
la traînée de poudre a aussi embrasé le
Havre Paris Normandie est allé
recueillir la parole des habitants de
Caucriauville en banlieue havraise
voiture brûlée bureau de poste et
commerçantiers le journal rapporte la
désolation là aussi et la stupéfaction
des riverains qui se dit sous le choc
caillasser le tramway du Havre retrouvez
plus circuler hier soir plus au sud la
colère ne retombe pas non plus non la
fièvre persiste commence ce matin
Sud-Ouest le journal revient sur la mort
d'un autre jeune homme dans des
circonstances assez proche de celle de
Naël pour ce qu'on en sait pour
l'instant elle ou c'est une camarade 19
ans et décédé le 14 juin à Saint-Yrieix
près d'Angoulême lors d'un contrôle
routier face à son refus d'obtempérer là
aussi le policier lui attiré une balle
mortelle dans le torse il a été mis en
examen lui aussi pour homicide
volontaire merci Samia merci beaucoup
pour cette revue de presse merci
Benjamin Morel merci de rester troussef
d'être venu ce matin merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis pour voir ou revoir
cette émission c'est sur notre
plateforme public sénat.fr et je vous
donne rendez-vous lundi très bonne
journée très bon weekend
[Musique]